new Democratic candidate for president
you know everyone so far has been
Republican candidate I think there are
now 655 Republican Kent yes president
not that many Democrats well there is a
new one former governor of Rhode Island
lincoln Chafee now yesterday Chafee said
an important part of his platform is
getting the us to finally adopt the
metric system it's a metric crowd all
right now to some people that may not
sound like the most popular or pressing
issue but Chafee is not backing off
check out his new campaign ad yeah
lincoln Chafee is 1.8 meters and seventy
two point seven kilograms of red-blooded
American some question his campaign
platform but don't judge him until
you've walked sixteen hundred nine point
three four metres in these shoes he'll
fight to ensure every hectare of this
country is safe and when it comes to
health care he won't budge 2.54
centimeters win will Chafee let Wall
Street off the hook win hell reaches of
cool zero degrees Celsius plus he
supports the popular movement to convert
the dollar to the euro lincoln Chafee
he'll be out of this race in point two
nanoseconds
[Applause]
hey thanks for watching please subscribe
to my youtube channel so they will stop
making me shoot these videos please